it's no exaggeration to say that unless
we do something these animals will be
extinct within five years five years
thankfully might be a push ten years
definitely I'm you're losing about 1,700
is what we would expect to lose this
year predominately in South Africa as
the report has just shown all for this
horn all for keratin which is our nails
yeah we could all just do this and we'll
get exactly the same thing unfortunately
the myths are there and it's about the
spelling those miss predominant Vietnam
so how are you doing that it's lots of
organizations working hard that's the
harder part almost is because that's
long-term there's no quick fix an
organization like ourselves at the
shoulder of trust is about boots on the
ground like you were seen in the footage
there aerial surveillance Rapid Response
saving them now so that the
organization's doing the long term
changing consumer beliefs consumer
understanding have got time to do it
when they've got that message across
there are actually still viable
populations of rhino and a similar thing
with elephants with um the ivory trade
now there's a lot of criticism about
Mozambican poachers but a lot of these
people and next to nothing and they if
they've got a chance to earn a few extra
US dollars or whatever in order to
maintain their families and that's what
they're going to do those are not the
people that you're looking for they're
not there's a lot of people get irate
and say we need to take out all the
poachers there will always be another
photo these are seriously impoverished
people and if you're waving tens of
thousands of dollars at them they're
going to do something they need to be
engaged in wildlife they need to be
supported and they need to see how it's
benefiting them in at the moment they're
not seeing that they're seeing wealthy
tourists come in enjoy these things and
leave and they don't see where they get
the benefits we need to engage them we
need to find ways to find alternative
employment for these people so that
they're not either poaching or acting is
informers for the poachers and who are
the middlemen and Irwin that's your
shady characters and very much organized
crime networks so the same people that
are involved in drug smuggling human
smuggling they've seen an easy
opportunity here it's relatively easy to
get rhino horn ivory out of Africa get
them into China and Vietnam and make a
quick buck and it's essentially it gets
it finds now just to clarify this this
Rhino is shaking because he's not fully
under it yes yeah nothing sorry and
nothing to worry about there at all yeah
okay and he's back on his feet again
there now they're the majestic animals
they are abs
expecting their perfect an almost 50
million years of evolution has gotten to
where they are so a lot of people will
talk about dehorning them more if
evolution has left them with a horn it's
for a purpose and just because humans
want to kill them doesn't mean we should
go oh let's just change how they look
change everything about that yes I
taking the whole off I mean don't they
need the warned about fighting with each
other great for finding a mate they do
use it for self-defense they dig for
food with it and the mums often guide
their babies with it so you know they do
need it and also if you do the dehorning
programs i think they estimated would
cost about 8.8 million dollars to dehorn
crude as rhinos every two years you'd
have to do it again and again and that's
not a solution that's that's the very
human way of saying well there's a
problem there's a way we can probably
fix it the solution is ending the demand
it's keeping them alive now ending the
demand that's what we need to do that
for the publishers get a program where
the idea was to put pink dye in their
holes what happened to them some there
are for about 1,500 dollars per rhino
there are things where they're putting
either dies or essentially poisons into
them to make the horn useless for any
purpose but presumably I don't know that
until you've taken it on it's kind of
it's kind of an issue there the animal
would still potentially be killed and
even d horned rhinos have been killed by
poachers if they've tracked them through
the bush for days if it's got any horn
when it's worth sixty thousand dollars a
kilo any amount is worth money to them
so they will still kill a deal on
Draenor now when I first started going
to start be sounds it's probably about
10 11 years ago and I you could see them
you know at all times oh yeah there's a
rhino will come back and look at that
one now you have to really hunt for the
violence is the white rhino not even the
black rhino what's happening so White's
gone about 20,000 left and then black
rhinos under 5,000 now so Kenya's got
about a thousand of those and then
they're dispersed and then South
Africa's got them as well so what we
just needs a strange when we just need
to do more to protect them it kind of
comes down to that we need to get people
investing more into multifaceted
approaches so it's having the boots on
the ground it's having the arrows events
having the k-9 units which are a
fantastic asset like ourselves we use
those in Kenya and last month alone 21
arrests all courtesy of these dogs which
it's using all these things and there's
lots of talk of drones and these other
things everything has a part to play but
there is no quick
I think that's what we need to examine
six is your camera tell people in the
Far East who are watching us right now
why they shouldn't be using right over
quite simply shouldn't be using it as it
will do nothing for you whatsoever and
you will wipe out a majestic species
there you go you heard it right there
and we all endorse that here at Sky News
as well of course thanks very much to do
for joining us your arms going use this
afternoon happen